[Music]
hello and welcome to New York I can John
Knorr I first think of it you're John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers answer your question give you
devious advice and review all the week's
news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon
how are you John I'm doing well Hank as
you know it's Olympic season which can
only mean one thing in our family it's
the marble imp exceeded that is actually
correct right now in our house we spend
12 hours a day watching the proper
Olympics and 12 hours a day watching the
marble Olympics to be clear I love the
Olympics I think the Olympics is great
and I want to I love these times when
this sort of feels a little bit more
like we're living in a globally
productive society and we're connected
by things that we like rather than
things that we hate and yes but also the
marble impacts John oh the marble
Olympics it's just it's just fantastic
every year Henry and I go all in on the
savage speeders and every year he or
Rangers break our hearts who don't know
what's happening there's a YouTube
channel called do you know how to
pronounce this John yella yellows marble
runs yeah and they are its it is a
channel of marble races and other marble
competitions and and this happens all
year round but then during Olympic
seasons both summer and winter there is
there is a marble limpets where marbles
compete against each other in various
events like high jump and speed downhill
speed runs and other is did they have a
lot there's a bunch of teams
yeah there's marble curling there's
marble curling which apparently this
year got they they cancelled the
Marshall curling because it was too
boring and they're really he's
recreating it a second time yeah well I
for one found every I find every moment
of the marble Olympics absolutely
engrossing and I just it it is
outlandish ly entertaining it
possibly entertaining and it just goes
to show you that while times are dark on
parts of YouTube on other parts of
YouTube
the marble impacts are showing us all
how we can come together and hate
everyone who roots for the arrangers
I've been I've been rooting for Team
Galactic and that's not going super well
so my backup team which is a new team
this year at the midnight wisps yeah and
might have been my team and they're
actually doing quite well
yeah our backup team is the Oceanics
which also that's Katherine's team and
they are not doing well they have not
had a good Olympic so far but the arc of
history is long and it bends towards the
savage speeders well I'm really excited
I'm really excited to see how the marble
Olympics goes this year it's it's fun is
especially good viewing for commercial
times cuz when you're watching the
Olympics you can't skip the commercials
because it's live and also it's the same
commercials over and over again and like
yes I'm aware that do you want me to buy
an exercise bike yeah or whatever
there's a lot of lot of Chevrolet
commercials man yeah yeah they would
like me to know that Chevrolet has won a
lot of awards and and look good on ya GM
thanks for making cars that people use I
think I'm not gonna say that until and
unless GM comes and sponsors this
podcast I do want to say something else
though of great importance you may
remember the amazing amazing tiger poem
I read written by a six-year-old last
week here on the pod mmm-hmm that poem
is published in a book and you can buy
the book the book is called you will be
able to say a thousand words and you can
buy it and it will support 826 DC which
is an awesome organization that brings
free writing programs for students
between the ages of 6 and 18 so we're
gonna put a link in the show notes to
that book so that you can buy it I have
bought a copy if that tiger poem is any
indication the book will bring me so
much joy and consolation cool alright
excellent and do you have a poem for us
today John also you can you can find the
Marvel Olympics by just googling Marble
Olympics or Marble Olympics it's not
difficult to discover if you would like
to enjoy this this piece of pure joy in
which you can see marbles competing
against each other completely free of
you know any of the any of the the human
story that goes into the Olympics right
both the great thing and the problem
with the Olympics is that it's all of
human stories the great thing about the
Marvel impacts is that you get to impose
human stories upon marbles and that in
general for whatever reason it just
works much better I don't have a poem
for today Hank we're gonna skip right
into the questions this first question
comes from Ellen who writes dear John
and Hank I have two dogs and two cats if
my dog Winston brings me a ball to throw
I throw it and both Winston and one of
the cats chase it and the cat gets there
first but Winston is ultimately the one
who returns the ball to me in this
situation whose ball is it I purchased
the ball Winston is keeping the activity
going but the cat is the one on the
other end of my throw so who is actually
in possession of the ball if a fight
should break out between the three of us
which one of us has the right to keep
the ball ah not gelatin-like a felon
Ellen well Ellen I have heard it said
and I don't know what this means that
possession is nine-tenths of the law so
I guess there's a 90% chance that
whoever is holding the ball owns the
ball well whoever is holding the ball in
a moment probably owns the ball in that
moment the question is legally who like
who has the right to sell the ball ah
well I see so the situation Ellen is
that you own both your dog and your cat
that would be my argument my argument
would be that even when the dog owns the
ball you own the ball because you decide
like when you say Winston drop it and
he's like no and then he say Winston
drop it again and he gets that sad I had
look on his face uh-huh
that's because he knows he's gonna drop
it right or or else you're gonna sell
Winston oh god hey don't take because he
won't give you a ball John the thing
that that that interests me most about
this question is the idea that can a
ball be owned by no one I mean I almost
think that it has to be owned by no one
in this case it's a bit of a
Schrodinger's ball situation really okay
I don't I think the ball is definitely
not alive but also kind of not data I
suppose no it's just that the ball is in
more than one state at the same time
like right ball the ball is both
Winston's and the cat's PS did the cat
not get a name I don't think the cat was
named I think it seems it seemed to me
that it was one of the cats and there's
multiple cats and we're not like maybe
it's a different cat each time it's
unclear that's pretty brutal Ellen you
know to have one named pet in your home
and just refer to your other pet as the
cat that's bright
yeah can we can we name the cat can we
name it like sharpie it's the first
thing that I saw on my desk that's great
I love it yeah so I think the cat
belongs to all of you together and you
have to make votes about its future and
you it's a module on situation all are
the cat the cat everybody yeah no
Winston owns the cat the ball owns the
cat and Ellen owns the cat and all three
of them have to vote about the cat's
future it's a democracy now it's a
co-ownership situation and yeah and
everybody has to an exactly one-third so
that nobody has a voting majority there
that's right I guess if you get two out
of three then you do decide what to do
with the the the ball I recently wanted
to John do a project for awesome perk
where I get a gather River rocks and I
paint them and put Henker fish on them
and then and then I realized that that I
didn't own those rocks and that actually
someone did that being the United States
government oh boy
because they own everything
they own the land you can't just take
stuff it's very strange that everything
it's kind of like everything is owned by
someone and there are these times when
like suddenly objects transfer ownership
from you and like sort of implicitly but
also maybe legally like when you put an
item in a trash can that item becomes
owned by the garbage company it's not
yours anymore kind of actually and if
you take if like a stranger take
something out of that trash can
there actually are they stealing from
the garbage company or is that owned by
no I think that they're technically
stealing from the garbage company can I
ask you a follow-up question Hank yes
please if for instance there are two to
three hundred thousand aluminum cans
full back doors rubber tires that appear
to have once belonged to four wheelers
etc in in the White River at any given
moment
aha does all of that belong to the
government I think so I feel like it
might belong I feel like it might be my
problem
I was kayaking it got briefly warm
enough for me to kayak here and when I
say briefly I mean for like 12 minutes
I was kayaking upriver and I literally
passed a door going down it had a
doorknob in it wait what John did you
try to open the door because maybe if
you'd gotten the right angle and you
could just like open it up there'd be a
no learning a situation yeah that is
exactly why I didn't to open the door I
like my life I'm not trying to fall into
some other dimension I saw Outlander I
don't want to be removed from my family
no no I did not open the door I did
immediately think if I open this door
I'm gonna lead a completely different
life and go to a different dimension and
live in a world probably were like I
don't know snicker bars are sentient or
something but I
I didn't I didn't open the door let's
move on to questions from another
question from our listeners we've gone
too far down the rabbit hole
okay I've also just googled who owns
trash so I definitely feel like we need
to we need to take a turn turn turn into
what did we call it last week hard
normal or some hard normal this next
question oh it's you you asked it us
it's my turn this next question comes
from DES who asks hey Hank and John
that's not the name of the podcast death
I was a little aggressive des hey when
you go somewhere and you accidentally
take some ants with you at home when you
go somewhere and you accidentally take
some ants with you do they just fit
right into the ant colony wherever you
end up or are they put in a constant
state of anxiety because their loved
ones are nowhere to be found
worried about ants death okay first of
all do you Hank Haley pink what why what
this note has a PS and you chose not to
read them yes and that I cannot believe
that you chose not to read the PS holy
snood I'm just bad at this god the PS is
can't wait to read an absolutely
remarkable thing which is Hanks book it
comes out in September and it's
available for pre-order now and Hank
just blatantly refused to read the PS
about his own book and how somebody is
excited to read it
okay now go on do ants experience ant
anxiety when put into a colony that is
not their home colony well I also it
seems that deaths frequently
accidentally takes ants somewhere well
that's true for any of us
do i oh yeah sure picnic baskets I'll
take the major way okay is this like
hitchhikers on the cuff on the cuffs of
your pants yeah do you think I have the
question you're the science person so
usually these ants die oh that's nice
well to be clear every ant dies and
that's just how it works
ants ants have their no immortal ants as
we've determined this
and ants have a basically I don't know
that I think they could halt like a
passport pheromone maybe it's what they
call it and and for some ant species the
passport pheromone is species specific
so any ant can go to another ant colony
and they'll just like hey what's up
Steve how's it going you're at it with
us now but but many and in fact I think
most ant species have colonies specific
passport pheromones and if they show up
at a new colony they will be killed as
an invader
I think but sometimes ants with this
actually happens sometimes with ants
with passport specific colonies specific
pheromones get incorporated into a
colony even though they probably
shouldn't the answer just sort of like
oh I get it
I see what this is it's not an attack
it's just Steve who you know got here on
the picnic basket from the lake but it
this all does depend on the ant finding
a colony of the same species to
integrate into that don't find a colony
they will die because they need the
support of the colony to survive and if
they find a colony of a different
species of ants they will definitely get
killed okay all right so you're saying
there's a chance I'm saying there's a
chance sometimes even two colonies will
come together and form a single colony
which is pretty unusual because usually
when usually colonies consider each
other antagonistic wow that's
interesting that's I mean I don't want
to get too deep into comparing ants to
humans
dot dot dot let's move on to the next
question but before we do that let's
plug the YouTube channel ants Canada
because if you're looking for weird
YouTube channels that are about very
specific but amazing things ants Canada
is a really great one as well and there
are different clans of ants that are
taken care of by this ant guy and he's
really excited and just it's one of my
favorite ways to spend 15 minutes you
plug two ants Canada last week
[Laughter]
you've now you know you've now
officially plugged ads Canada more than
you've plugged your own book this next
question comes from bathroom writes Dear
John and Hank my name is Beth and I'm an
optical dispenser my job is to help
people choose new glasses and many wait
wait wait optical dispenser definitely
sounds like a machine no it doesn't it
sounds like a person she might spend
like the opticals like like a despit
like if that is that a phrase from
another country I could be you dispense
like there's two two situations in which
you dispense something one you are a
vending machine two it's marijuana
oh no I think three its glasses my job
is to help choose new glasses and many
people I help get a huge amount of
anxiety when selecting new glasses yeah
no joke Beth me too oh yeah many people
want to change their look but don't know
what to look for other whereas other
people very much don't want to change
their look and get upset when we don't
have the exact same glasses so I come to
you brothers green as Hank really hasn't
changed the look of his glass as much
and John has changed multiple times I'm
a big fan of your current pair John they
do good things for your jawline thank
you Beth
I feel like you may have some excellent
dubious advice how do I get people to
feel more at ease when choosing their
glasses huh it's not easy I mean oh it's
funny you should mention that Beth
because I'm reading your question
through lenses that I can just barely
see out of because I like these glasses
but I am nervous to even try to get new
lenses into them because what if they
break and then I have to get new glasses
and it would be such a nightmare yeah
I'm looking at your glasses right now
John because I could not call them to
bind sure and they do look nice I think
that they do look nice and and they do
do nice things for your jaw line and I
don't think that your neck is
disappearing at all the way that some
people in vlogbrothers comments for some
reason are saying well it's fine it's
it's good because the nice thing about
people criticizing my appearance is that
I don't actually worry much about my
appearance but I do worry about like
what horrible diseases I might have that
are resulting and these changes to my
appearance so I spent a lot of time
googling what might be wrong with
neck anywhere no i'm throwin i have I I
worry that my teeth have changed shape
over the years and that they're moving
around huh yeah it's really actually
pretty amazing to have like a least one
video of me talking every week for the
last 11 years so I can go and be like
was my tooth like that before or is that
new
it is very been that way for for at
least 11 years so I think yeah ya know
it is a very weird thing to look at your
face for several hours a week while
editing yeah
ones videos and I don't think that it is
particularly good for one's overall
quality of health but I like making
vlogbrothers videos and I'm grateful for
the opportunity but to get to Beth's
question Hank okay let's do it what in
your experience what have been things
that people have said that have helped
you pick out glasses well I think it
helps to have somebody who you trust a
lot so so so in general like
establishing yourself as an authority is
actually something that that can go a
long way and ways to do that are to say
like hi I'm Beth I this is this is what
I do and and my clients include Nicolas
Cage no no that's Harry well Han Lindsay
Lohan the last time Hank meaningfully
engaged with popular culture was
apparently 2007 anyway that is a
terrible advice it is good advice to
establish your authority but the way you
you do that I think is saying hi I'm
Beth and I am an optical dispenser and
for the last X number of years I've
worked with people to get them glasses
that fit well and that they like the
look of and that's what I want to do
with you and it may take a while but
we'll be patient and we'll get something
that you're really happy with and I
think encouraging people in that way and
then I I really like the specificity you
used even when talking about my glasses
where you think
you know what the glasses bring out what
they help with what the downsides might
be you know if the lenses are really
small it might affect your field of
vision etc just showing your expertise
through calm generous kind
readings of the situation I don't think
that's gonna make it an unanxious
experience for a lot of people because
it's a big choice it's it's you know the
one thing that I wear every single day
for four years at a time so it is a big
important choice and sounds like it's on
your face man it makes your face look
different and when I take my glasses off
people are like oh is that man yeah I
don't look like myself without my
glasses so I mean I I think one thing I
like about your question Beth is that
you obviously understand why your job's
important and and why it helps people
and I think if you just bring that
attitude to it that you're there to try
to help people and try to be a calm
presence in a difficult situation I
think that's uh that's that's the right
track to me absolutely and and then you
know I what helps me honestly is having
Catherine there because Catherine I feel
like is the one who has to look at me
all the time
and and so ultimately it's more her
decision than mine sure this next
question comes from NIV who asks dear
Hank and John I'm a seventeen year old
girl and my parents at least my mom is
hell-bent on making me study math for my
undergrad well my dad is a bit more cool
not only a bit with me doing economics
the love of my life I feel like I'm
letting my parents down by not being
enthusiastic about getting a degree in
math I love the subject but the syllabi
for a good math courses cover all the
topics I utterly despise how do I break
the news to my parents that I might not
in fact be doing math and that I will be
doing economics to go on to become like
the president of a country or a
successful businessperson with no
regrets live long and prosper native
isn't economics and math the same thing
uh what I gotta say to knibbs parents is
come oh yeah I mean your child could be
studying
12th century French poetics by the way I
know there are people in our audience
who are studying 12th century French
poetics and I thank you that is a good
and noble work but I mean from the
perspective of parents who are worried
about your you're never they're worried
about ya in business I'm sorry I cannot
you gonna be fine if just study
economics just this like a like a long
history do you have like like
generations of mathematicians in your
family like is your great-great-great
grandfather like Gauss or mm like some
other famous old mathematician Blaise
Pascal hmm yeah I mean even Pascal
though wasn't just a mathematician can't
you make the case to your parents that
you're gonna learn a lot of math along
the way to your economics degree and
also it seems to me that economics
majors are very employable like I can
you just promised your parents are
focused economics
yeah that's clearly not the concern if
you're trying to get a job economics
it's definitely better than pure maths
though and often if you have a math
degree you're gonna end up working in
something related to economics like
finance but in terms of like let like
put aside job training I'm not
interested in that argument cuz it seems
like your parents probably just want you
to continue the line of the hundreds or
possibly thousands of years of
mathematicians in your family yes and
what what you say that that is I want to
do the thing I want to do and you didn't
have a child because you wanted the
child to become one particular thing you
had the child because you wanted the
child to be able to decide and make good
things happen that they wanted to do and
that level of that level of control
either is is sort of out like out sized
in your own mind NIV and and you are
sort of perceiving to like more pressure
than they intend to be putting on you to
choose one specific career path or it's
just it's just too much
they should not be doing that and you
should be choosing to do the thing and
being in feel free to and excited about
doing the thing that you love and you
want to do alternately I don't know if
there's a double major in your country I
know a lot of places there aren't double
majors but it seems like it'd be easy to
do a double major in math and economics
because half the classes of the dang
same like I took an economics class in
college and it was all flippin math I
mean I maybe I don't understand what
math is but it felt like math to me
there were a lot of numbers and I had to
use those numbers to create a lot of
geometrical curve shapes so I don't know
it felt very mathematical anyway we wish
you luck me I'm sorry that you're going
through this difficult time
I hope that you get to pursue all of
your passions in life I want to get to
another question though Hank this one
comes from Heather yep all right she
writes dear John and Hank my name is
hella and I grew up on a farm that my
family has owned for over 300 years wait
is this like the mathematician question
except with farms instead yes
I am the second of four children all of
whom are now adults according to oldest
Rhett my older brother has first dibs on
the farm then me and then our younger
sisters elders threat by the way which
I'm very sure I'm mispronouncing is the
ancient Scandinavian thing where that
decides how land gets passed down
through families very goodness and it
has its own Wikipedia page it does that
my older brother has first dibs on the
farm then me and then our younger
sisters it has always been expected that
one of us should take over the farm as
it is the norm but all of us have moved
away and I'm pretty sure none of us
actually want to be farmers I'm not
saying there's anything wrong with being
a farmer it's just not really for me our
Father brought it up a few years ago
that we should decide who gets to take
over the farm and well is it wrong to
want to sell a farm that has been in our
family for several hundred years do we
owe our forefathers to sacrifice enough
to keep this farm in our family there's
no guarantee that we would be able to
find a buyer that would keep the farm a
farm but I know that I really
do not want to be a farmer ever since I
was a little girl I've been quite
squeamish around a lot of the stuff that
happens on a farm and I really have not
grown out of it but have you seen how
many movies there are where the people
who want to sell the family farm are the
villains no silent e's hella uh I feel
like maybe in in Norway there are more
of those films because I haven't seen
that many I've seen a few but it would
appear that like this is a pretty
important and big part of Norwegian
culture that I had no idea about just
from reading the Wikipedia page for
oldest threat which I think I just
knocked that pronunciation out of the
park and it is a fascinating law and it
is the actual existing law in Norway and
if somebody who isn't in the family buys
the farm the family members have the
right to get it back which is currently
about ten years so they can just buy it
for the additional price plus the cost
of any improvements if if you sell if
you like get rid of the farm you could
get it back potentially though there are
also rules about making that not a thing
but I bet we have different opinions
about this well I mean ever since I came
to to Montana I have had a different
sort of feeling about farms and families
and and like the the seriousness of this
not that like I think that this should
like this is how you know should it
impact you it's just like my
understanding of this has changed a lot
having known farmers been friends with
generational farmers and also new
farmers and seen the kind of like the
difficulty of that job it is a very
difficult and not particularly thankful
job in which you have to live far away
from population centers and that is
pretty isolating and it is it is a
difficult difficult thing to do for a
living and and also the strife and
difficulty that it creates within
families when you have this
extraordinarily valuable thing but you
don't like the way of turning that you
know that huge amount of land
you know compared to what most people
own in terms of land into money is is a
really stressful difficult thing because
you're always taking out loans to buy
the seed and to work the land and then
at the end of the season hopefully you
can pay those loans off and that happens
every year and it's just really intense
but also like that responsibility that
people feel to their to their ancestors
to and to the institution that they have
been raised in and part of for their
whole lives but also for like their
entire sort of like imagined cultural
history which is a very real thing it's
the intensity of that is you know like I
wouldn't have understood it if I hadn't
seen it you know I certainly didn't have
an experienced it firsthand but I've
seen it secondhand yeah I mean my
feeling is that you should wait hella
you shouldn't make the decision now if
you don't have to you know maybe my
father saying I I want to know what the
future holds but I think you can say
well you know right now you you have the
farm and we're so grateful that you do
and we we love we love it and we want to
support you in any way that we can and
when it comes time to make a decision we
will make a decision because I also
don't think that you can really know how
you'll not only how you'll feel but how
you're at least three siblings will feel
what when the time comes to really make
the decision about you know if there
comes a time when your father feels like
he can't do the work or can't oversee
the work then you have to have that hard
hard conversation but I think you have
to have it with all of your siblings
because it is it is so complicated Hank
as you say I mean there is something
very powerful about knowing that this is
the place where your ancestors bones are
in many cases literally and and
certainly that you know you're doing the
same work in the same place that they
were there's something there's something
powerful about that and something
comforting about that but at the same
time it's very easy to romanticize that
and hella having grown up on a farm
knows that in RAC the actual work is
utterly unromantic yeah
can confirm having our farmer friends
yeah I mean yeah yeah you you have to
slaughter exactly one animal before you
completely lose the sense of romance
yeah I agree with you and it doesn't say
it doesn't sound to me like you've had a
ton of conversations with your siblings
about this especially and I would
suggest definitely having those
conversations sooner rather than later
which reminds me that today's podcast is
brought to you by conversations with
your siblings conversations with your
siblings it's the whole podcast podcast
is also brought to you by generations of
mathematicians stretches back deep deep
into your family history and you can't
go into economics because of it I guess
maybe and today's podcast is also
brought to you by aunts Canada aunts
Canada Hank won't stop Pro mowing it and
of course this podcast is brought to you
by the marble impacts marble impacts
available at Ella's marble runs on
YouTube where you can spend your
commercial time while watching the
Olympics watching non-human competitors
made of glass we also have a real
sponsor today Hank and I'm actually
literally opening up my rx bar right now
I don't know if you heard that but I am
so excited about the sponsor because it
is a product that I really really like
I'm gonna have a bite while you talk
about it I mean it's kind of shocking to
me that you still have any rx bars they
sent us a pack of them and I oh no I
brought these oh okay yeah they are a
they're an energy bar I have to eat fast
quite a lot and and I like to actually
have a variety of kinds of energy bars
it's nice that we live in a world where
that's possible now and these ones are
they are they are tasty they are healthy
they are a really good sort of
intermediate snack because they're they
don't have like too much in them so it's
not like I'm eating a whole meal it's
not a meal replacement it's sort of like
I get me through to the next meal
mounted
and they're easy to eat and and I like
the taste of them a lot oh they're
delicious they're incredible yeah this
sort of like the new the they're sort of
they're made a lot of figs is sort of
the stuff that binds it all together and
ace o dates our dates and figs different
I don't actually know but this is so
delicious so they're made of figs
of egg whites date it's still dates
still dates they're made of dates egg
whites and nuts pretty much and then
there's like flavoring to make them
taste good and different from each other
and there's both like fruity flavors
like raspberry and blueberry and more
sort of cute like chocolate flavors like
chocolate peanut butter and that kind of
thing salted chocolate so really it just
has like very clear ingredients like on
the front of it it just says three egg
whites 14 peanuts two dates and the only
other things it has in it or chocolate
cocoa and sea salt it's just it is a
great I am a genuine genuine fan of
these are X bars anyway yeah go to our X
bar comm Dear John or rx bar.com slash
dear Hank and enter the promo code Dear
John or dear Hank at checkout and get
25% off of your first order and I'm
telling you you are not going to be
disappointed especially with the the
peanut e ones I'm more of a peanut
person than I am
a other nut person but they're all
honestly they're all really good I do
yeah they had they come in 11 different
flavors I have had I think all of them I
think they sent me all of the flavors
and I didn't not like any of the flavors
I had they're good for breakfast on the
go snack throw it I like if I'm getting
on an airplane it's really good to have
something just in case I'm gonna get
hungry suddenly pre or post-workout it's
really good cuz they're not like too
intense and aren't gonna like overwhelm
my system and make me feel bad while I'm
exercising and give me heartburn or
anything I just like it oh they're
delicious again that's our X bar dot
coms last year John or dear Hank and you
enter the promo code Dear John or dear
Hank and checkout you get 25% of your
first order and
do that I'm almost done with mine ah
I've got so much energy to get back to
the podcast but I'm talking like a
chipmunk because I got a lot of stuff in
my mouth all right let's go John
this next question comes from Crystal
who asks dear Hank and John why should i
preorder Hanks upcoming book and
absolutely remarkable for pre-order now
7 months in advance
I can pre-order the book in early
September at the meantime use that $20
to like I don't know invest in the stock
market put it in the bank for small
interest or dig a hole to bury it in the
ground PS it comes out September 25th
and is available for pre-order now best
regards crystal crystal thanks for doing
the hard work for me all right crystal I
want to offer you a couple of futures in
which you're going to be very grateful
that you ordered Hanks book seven months
in advance future number one the entire
world economy has collapsed okay
everything the stock market the has
collapsed but not only that all of the
savings accounts the people there was a
bank run and people tried to get their
cash out and it turned down the FDIC
couldn't insure all of the deposits sure
and suddenly the money that you had in
the bank is worth pennies on the dollar
but you know what you have crystal you
have a physical a really beautiful
physical object a hardcover book that
you can use not only for reading and
consolation but also when it becomes
necessary to beat off the invaders that
are attacking you because the social
fabric has completely disintegrated or
it's an absolute emergency to start a
fire or or or barter because everyone
knows that this book is worth the amount
that it was when you purchased it so it
was when you bought it it was worth you
know $20 or whoever and then now it's
still worth $20 actual money even though
$20 bill might be only able to buy you
like a stick of gum
so this thing is the new
currency of the future that's right in
the future people are just going to be
handing around hardcover books in
exchange for books John my just the one
just the one book it's basically Bitcoin
it's my book is it's a crypto currency
that's right it's a great oil is a book
crystal get in on the ground floor of
this exciting new cryptocurrency that
comes with a physical book it is a no
way a pyramid scheme crystal but if you
don't get in at the very beginning you
will lose all of your money
[Laughter]
crystal the real reason tourism crystal
the real reason to order Hank's book now
is so that you don't forget to do it
later and also because it helps the
publisher measure enthusiasm and
excitement about the book and it is very
helpful to both the future of the book
and the book's author when the publisher
believes that there are lots of people
who are excited about it so really if
you have been considering pre-ordering
Hanks book please do please do it now
really it's it is and I'm not just
saying this I wouldn't just say this I
would find ways to talk about it that
that that weren't dishonest but I
wouldn't be as a few civ as I'm about to
be it is a really really wonderful book
and it explores what now feels like so
fascinatingly and it explores what fame
feels like and the way that it distorts
your worldview and the way that our
general worship of fame has distorted
the wider the wider culture in really
fascinating moving brilliant ways it is
a special special novel so you will also
be grateful to have been in on the
ground floor of the story of an
absolutely remarkable thing but the
biggest thing that you can do is help
the book and its author by communicating
to the publisher that people are excited
about it yeah and and that has happened
and and so you know the people I'm
working with our at
penguin our have been so supportive and
excited and so I really appreciate
everybody who has pre-ordered it really
does help and whether you do that online
or whether you go to your bookstore and
if you're wondering how you pre-order
something in a bookstore you go in and
you say I would like to pre her to this
book and they will say ok I will call
you when it's in and that's that and it
works all right Hank we've got a
question from MP who writes Dear John
and Hank when you're on the phone with
someone in the call drops who's in
charge of calling back the originator of
the first call since they started it or
should you think of it as taking turns
I often panic and quickly try to decide
if I'm the more adult person in the
conversation so I should take the reins
and call back but even I know that's not
a great method please help me to adult
better bad at avoiding social
awkwardness MP what what happens when
when we drop a call it's usually like we
both do it right like call it back at
the same time and then sometimes we both
get busy signal's and then a lot of
times I'll be on your voicemail and I'll
be like why don't you pick up your phone
we were talking 30 seconds and I'll see
and I'll be like oh right he's trying to
get to me too okay
yeah yep we need a system for this Hank
is it like the younger person cuz you
have to have some like objective thing
because the call drops for both of you
at the same time so it's not it's not
something to do with the context of the
phone call that's basically beyond that
so like whose name comes first in the
alphabet kind of thing I like that it's
who's the name that you usually use to
refer to that person so not necessarily
they're given first name whatever you
know if you call them shrimp dissin
shrimp you know if you call them Apple
then Apple whatever it is the the first
letter of that name that you use to talk
to the person the person whose name is
closest to the beginning of the alphabet
is the person who who does the callback
caveat if more than five seconds pass
then it's a complete free-for-all
because then you start to worry like
well did they hang up on me on purpose
or did they get in some kind of horrible
accident like are they is there an
emerging right is there an emergency so
don't like don't say oh well you know
Apple hasn't called me back
I guess that Apple just thought the
phone call was over do call them back
because for all you know they might be
at thought you know like out at the
bottom of a crevasse I once called Sarah
after badly injuring my knee while
trying to walk up the hill after
kayaking and if Sarah hadn't answered
the phone I probably would have just
stayed down there for 127 hours
John what if the phone call is between
our cousin Mike and our Uncle Mike oh
that's something I hadn't thought of it
that's a great point Hank what does they
have a exact same eye yeah not only they
say that same last name too I think it
goes to the middle goes to the middle
name I think it goes to the middle name
now in the case of our cousin Mike and
our Uncle Mike unfortunately that is not
a tie breaker so then I think you've got
to go to junior or senior and since Jay
comes before so in the alphabet I think
our cousin might cause back our uncle
Mike in that situation that also would
happen just by virtue of the fact that
our Uncle Mike would be like Mike's
gonna call me back
oh yeah no I can't see our Uncle Mike
really rushing to do anything phone call
yeah just I love my Uncle Mike so much
he's an amazing amazing person I really
I just I admire so much about him he is
the coolest he is such a cool guy
however if if there is a disconnected
call the chances that he's gonna call me
back are well below zero negative
negative chances that you're gonna get
the callback from from Uncle Mike
speaking of negative chances Hank can I
share with you the news from AFC whoa
oh I'm sorry I've been following and I
feel like I'm be a my bad luck
I don't know so good in January so very
very very bad in February AFC Wimbledon
have slipped back into the dreaded
relegation so currently in 21st place
just ahead of the franchise currently
applying its trade in Milton Keynes Hank
I am NOT a professional scriptwriter of
third tier English football yeah but if
I were if I were writing the narrative
of the 2017 2018 season I think we all
know where it goes from here it comes
down to the last of the season on May
5th and either the franchise is going
down or the Dons are going down and the
pressure is unbelievable and I vomit 35
times that morning having flown from the
United States to England the night
before and I'm completely unable to
enjoy myself and really regardless of
the outcome I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to be happy that that is where the
narrative of this season is headed there
are still 14 games to try to avoid that
narrative but yeah I mean it's been a
very very bad February that's the really
the only thing that that can be said
about it it might change hopefully it
will change but the Dons lost 4-2 to
Plymouth Argyle 3-1 to Northampton Town
and that was after a 2-1 loss to Bari so
it's been a difficult week we've got a
game against Bristol Rovers coming up
and then Peterborough I don't know it's
just been a bad month man yeah yeah I
mean you're scoring goals to like none
of these are these are nil numbers yeah
it's like the most recent was like two
four and it's like two would have been
good enough in the first half of the
season to win like every game yeah I
know I know it's just been it's it's
also pushing the defense up to try and
increase nice I watched I watched all
three of these games that we've lost so
maybe I'm bad luck actually although we
also lost to Rotherham Rotherham rotor
Ham I know everyone's criticizing we
might pronounced
of it but I'm not gonna back down anyway
I watched all three of these games and
they just like they don't look they just
look like behind the game like that they
don't look like they're running at the
speed that the opponents are running at
they they just look kind of confused at
the back I don't know it's frustrating
and pretty scary but we'll see where it
goes from here I mean just really have
to hope that the Dons find a way to stay
up yeah well I don't know I feel like I
feel like you just having to run a bad
luck and that's gonna come back I hope
you're right I hope you're right what's
the news from Mars John so you know the
Mars 2020 Rover getting ready to go to
Mars you also know that sometimes pieces
of Mars actually end up on earth and
this is one of the ways that we've
actually been able to study a little bit
more about how Mars what Mars is like
because we haven't ever been able to
like bring a piece of Mars back for us
to hold but because of you know asteroid
impact and and you know various times in
the history of the solar system pieces
of Mars have actually been blasted into
space and then occasionally one of those
pieces of Mars will land on earth and we
will find one now we've done that a
number of times in these Martian
meteorites are extremely prized and all
of them are of them are you know in
scientific institutions and being
studied a piece one of those Martian
meteorites piece of it is actually gonna
be sent back to Mars Wow Mars 2020 Rover
Wow this is not like this is not just a
reunification to say hey Mars you lost
this we found it and we wanted to bring
it back to you because you know the
possession is nine-tenths of the law
so this is yours but uh you know it's
not exactly ours either so but because
there's this instrument it's called
the scanning habitable environments with
Ramanand
luminescence for organics and chemicals
which if that sounds like a really
awkward acronym it's because it is it
acronym for Sherlock oh that comes out
in the end
it needs a calibration target to like
basically to know exactly a bunch of
things about this rock and thus it can
like calibrate on the rock and then it
can like get better more precise data
about the rocks that it's measuring on
the surface of Mars whom they wanted to
use a rock that was Mars like and so
instead of like picking a rock that on
earth that had a lot of Martian like
Mars like properties they are using a
piece of Mars that we found on earth Wow
Wow we'll just brave frickin cool that
is pretty freakin cool man that is yeah
science so yeah I'm only about 200
Martian meteorites have ever have been
confirmed to be only 200 meteorites have
been confirmed to be from Mars
so this is a pretty pretty pretty you
know next level thing to do but it's
very cool that is cool that is cool
well congratulations on your forthcoming
reunify reunification project uh-huh I
can only hope that in 2020 when that
happens AFC wimbledon will be playing in
the third tier of English football in
their new home at plough Lane but time
will tell in the meantime Hank what did
we learn today
John we learned that ants have special
passport pheromones that allow them to
know whether or not an ant should be
friends or you kill them we learned that
the marble infix is arguably the best
Olympics but definitely in the top two
and we learned that my new book an
absolutely remarkable thing comes out
September 25th and it's going to be the
next big thing in cryptocurrency
hahahaha and lastly we learned several
ways not to pronounce oldest fret
Aldus flats all right Hank
thank you for parting with me thanks
everybody for listening we're gonna
record our patrons only podcast this
weekend Ryan's right now over and you
can find out more patreon.com slash dear
Hank and John but thank you again for
potting with me and to everybody who
listens and sends in your questions
we don't answer more of them they are an
absolute delight to read and it brings
us so much joy to be able to do this
every week and thank you John this
podcast is produced by rosianna halse
rojas and sheridan Gibson it's edited by
nicholas jenkins our head of community
and communications is victoria bon
giorno our music in the beginning and
the end and for this weekend Ryan sis by
the great to gunnarolla and as they say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]